joining us right here on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line uh fresh
off of a remarkable 205 yard rushing
performance
of the minnesota vikings who desperately
needed it on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line is dalvin cook back here in
the rich eisen show how you doing dalvin
what's up rick how are you doing
you're doing good
i would say so i'll be honest i can
confirm this source can confirm you're
doing good
i
how are you feeling today
i feel good
you know at that game you always sore
but you know i feel good as far as like
coming out the game clean and stuff yeah
i was good well i mean my god all right
so let me let me because i know you uh
i'm sure don't want to talk about
injuries and things like that players
don't want to talk about injury but
you're carted off the field 11 days
before your 200-yard performance did you
like how how hurt are you how banged up
are you gentlemen no it is it is what
they said is you know all the reports
that they say you know i told my label
um
and that that's in frame game but
yeah that's that's it but i've been i've
been working at screaming hard you know
me and my trainers and the spent the
conditioning coaches you know the
coaches been like making sure they
monitor you know my my my work load and
practice and stuff so i've been i've
been good i just been grinding you know
getting my shoulder back stronger
and so what are what it what did you did
you wear something in particular last
night to harness it to to prevent any
serious injury from happening dalvin
yeah i would have same harness two years
ago um
when we played against new orleans in
the playoff game um
so yeah i will harness that you know
kind of
not put myself in the position to not
let it happen again in order to kind of
keep me you know in a stable position
well you had a huge game against the new
orleans saints in that game as well dude
you're gonna keep the harness even if
you might not need it i mean uh if
you're superstitious like that sort of
thing
gentlemen i wouldn't say i'm
superstitious but like you know just
just going by the protocol you know
just make sure i take care of myself so
you know i got to keep it home okay
don't just keep doing what i do
sticking to it so were you were you
feeling good in the morning and then
that was part of it i i mean how did you
get ready for yesterday's game to get
out there on the field with a a torn
labrum because you have two of them too
right you have two of them you have one
in the other shoulder too correct
no i don't okay you don't all right so
you've got one in the shoulder that you
you tore and so um how did you get ready
walk me through your thursday
um i was feeling pretty good all week
though like when they went to play
against detroit
i kind of like went through like my
normal routine of doing treatment you
know because the trainers and stuff went
to the game so i was at home and i had
the stuff i needed to do treatment so i
kind of did treatment and i felt good
like coming into monday and then i just
told the trainer i seen doc
you know he looked at me he checked me
out put me through some emotions and i
was comfortable with the stuff that he
did and put my and put my shoulder into
positions so i was like
you know next thing to detect if it's
strong enough to go out there and
compete you know at high level you know
i was i was able to know
move around weights and do the things
that i do and but i was kind of like the
deciding factor of me going out there
and being safe on the football field
and then you start running like you did
um
when was the
i mean right before the first snap did
you is that in the back of your head or
you're like i'm free i'm ready to go
like how does that work for somebody in
your position
yeah i know i know i put the work in
like i know i put the work in like to go
out there and just like you know i play
the game with no regret you know that
injuries and still cover the game so you
know i
i won't put myself in harm's way and if
it you know whatever happens no i just
live within
and there's no regroup
dalvin cook here on the rich eisen show
were you surprised at how
large the holes that you were running
through and how long you were going
without contact
on thursday night yeah um
we they did a great job with um
putting together a game plan all week
you know we was believing like we
believed in the game plan like just just
seeing how everything was getting drawn
up like we knew like we had a chance to
go we're gonna make some plays we just
had to take advantage of those players
and i think we could did a good job with
that last night
all right now let me get let me get to
the 60 million dollar question here
dalvin cook why do the vikings have such
trouble finishing games you're up 29
nothing and that game turned into a nail
butter i don't need to go through the
entire year but you know uh difficulty
winning games that you were up
difficulty closing games that you were
up
why
no that's a good question no that's a
question we've been getting asked all
year and you know
steady going through these games over
and over is something like we not
shining away from you know we're looking
at it like looking there right in his
eyes and trying to figure the problem
out you know just just like everybody
else man we're not gonna we're not gonna
stop you know trying to figure out you
know why we can't finish team because i
know we can't we got the team to do it
so it's just up to us you know squarely
on
on these leaders on the team to get
these guys together and and figure it
out well what is what is your role on
all of that you know as a leadership for
you dalvin um
yeah just
know that that team that played in the
first half last night was you know was
lights out we was clicking on all
settlers
we just got to continue that energy
going into the second half and that's
just my job to keep pushing that message
you know letting everybody know we still
got a shot to go get in the playoffs you
know we still got something to keep
playing for is there a sense of a let up
though i mean like
does it
again i i know i i know there's no
specific answer
to the questions i'm putting in front of
you and i'm trying to just
you know put in front of you though the
questions that
die hards of the vikings are asking
um you know as they look down at their
bitten off fingernails this morning you
know so and
you know is there anything for me you
know coming from dalton i just you know
we trying to figure the problem out as a
whole as a team and
you know we want to stop putting our
fans through those
nerve-racking games you know it's the
same for us on the sideline you know
watching our defense or our defense
watching our offense or us watching our
kicker make a kick or you know whatever
the situation is so you know we trying
to we trying to figure this thing out we
got four more games
left i think so you know we got a shot
to go to go win some big time games and
not put ourselves in those situations
how far can you go dalvin how far can
you go
we can go we can go we just got to keep
getting to keep getting our confidence
going and just keep playing ball
and not worry about those games that
we've been talking about you know those
games that
that that came down to the minute to the
minute and the seconds that we didn't
win but we got to put that behind us and
just keep going
dalvin cook here on the rich eisen show
uh was that the best game you've ever
played
last night um that's the most fun i had
i had fun last night
it was a fun game we had fun i know my
whole life looked like they was having
fun so yeah it was a fun game
and then just but the in the mere fact
again that you you were so um
i mean if i told you when you were being
carted off uh in santa clara california
just to two weeks ago not even that uh
this game would be possible what would
you have told me
darling
um i probably couldn't have answered it
uh how i was feeling after that game i
was kind of down on myself i was kind of
you know in the place that's why you
know i'm grateful for my teammates and
my family and stuff so i i just feel
like you know injuries come and they go
but you know
in that time i just feel like my team
needed me to be there and i wasn't there
so like
but after the game i felt like my
shoulder was kind of banged up but you
know i just said i'm gonna put my head
down the ground and you know i looked up
and
you know i was able to go out there and
compete so you're feeling fine today you
got this many bye now and um and so
just in theory your shoulder should not
be a problem for the rest of the year as
you go about your business for the
minnesota vikings yeah
yeah just stand on it stand fine soon
i'll be good to go the rest of you all
right alvin cook you know um i'll just
say it's screwed you're on my fantasy
team way to go man
way to go dalvin cook
that was fantastic
that was just all of it i know that's
very impressive unprofessional thing for
me to say you know
are you hearing from me are you hearing
from people about that very subject
matter today dalvin have you heard about
that
from people yeah
okay well i i i'm glad i'm not the first
that makes me feel better but that was
it's
uh
tell the whole story rich well i mean
tell the whole story tell mr dalvin the
whole story
we had a big debate about this yesterday
well i mean like do we play you in
fantasy you know and and you know
because yeah i just didn't want to see
you come in and out of the game and all
that sort of business i feel you i feel
you you understand right yeah okay i
totally understand yeah okay good
because it's not about
us and that's that's the proper word
it's not me and you it's an us thing you
know it's not it's nothing's going to
come between the two of us dalvin
you know but but i was concerned and
then i saw you get 24 yards in that
first series that wound up with no
points and then oh my gosh 30 yard
carries here and there
did you know when you hit the locker
room that you had a buck 53 and change
are you were you aware of the numbers as
you were racking them up
no i wasn't when it popped up on the
screen like i've seen it like when
everybody else seemed like it popped up
on the screen and
i've seen it like everybody else
and then you're like okay all right and
then you went for 200 and you got it um
yeah then my whole line like my old line
like they weren't gonna let me fall
short of that 200 like they were they
was pushing forward okay good because
there's a five-yard uh five-point bonus
for me in my league again i'd like to
keep bringing it back to me
for that
you know
all i know is you you put me in a
rocking chair on sunday man and i
greatly appreciate that for this uh this
week 14. uh almost as much as you
calling into the show which i greatly
appreciate as well darwin so thanks
again
i really appreciate that anything uh
anything else that you know if you need
if you need ice if you need uh you know
anything else just you let me know and
i'll make sure you get it okay that's
great
all right take care darwin thanks for
the call see you now that's alvin cook
everybody
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here